Jeanne had a little apartment at the
bel-air hotel Jean was supposed to do
the little prince they delayed his role
in it for three months so that he could
work in our picture and daddy was very
kind very good remember there was
expensive we're speaking of Alan Ladd
jr. who's in the head of production of
2075 Jean I had a little like bungalow
and a fireplace and the only thing he
asked for he was so crazy team was jean
is still crazy but he kept saying to me
the only thing is I would meet him I'd
have dinner at home and I'd run over and
I'd be there by 7:30 or 8 o'clock and
then when we were writing this while I
was editing Blazing Saddles anyway I ran
over and I had to bring a box while I
brought a box at the beginning a big box
of Earl Grey tea he loved Earl Grey tea
and digestive cookies their English cook
is I think they make you go I'm not sure
they're there a brown cinnamon like
crunchy cookie and I had to eat like
four or five a night you know to keep
him company and drink this this ballsy
that kept me up on what but what are you
saying I said you're to keep your balls
what no no no would like it all right ha
ha ha I didn't understand you no no no I
think anyway digestive they were called
digestives for some reason yeah help
your digestion oh I see very good I
never figured that one out anyway so we
took our time and every night we'd write
a scene and we the only we were puzzled
they didn't it was only one character
that that puzzled us in the writing we
knew you know course was the easiest one
because she was she was in Rebecca
he was a terrible person who ran the
house in the Hitchcock picture and she
was easy Jean she was easy only because
we knew we had it but we hadn't really
truly an incredible actress and we knew
he could just throw it apart and we
didn't have to worry about it you know
that was that really i Gor wasn't we
didn't know what the hell I know they
called himself i Gor I'm sorry
you called him I Gordon I thought we
wrote that in the script
yeah and then I said it that's true she
did say but anyway
Kenny Mars inspector Kemper was
estranged so great and on the first day
of shooting I said to Kenny
you remember you were there I said to
Kenny when Kenny was shooting I said
Kenny your German accent is so good it's
so Luba Bavarian it's so perfect I don't
understand a [ __ ] word yourself on a
word not one word I said don't be such a
great German actor just clear it up
enough so we know what the hell you say
and when it was difficult jobs if the
Ranger system acting crazy
hahahaha you know we'd look at each
other
finally
finally we got we got he he got it right
but it took a long time didn't I come
and took a long time out there since us
solving Kenny Mars was a tough one